when are we going to see James Callen
brusse crowdfund oh it's not gonna
happen I'm not gonna crowdfund why
because I feel like it's begging and
it's going please please please give me
money I want money for a film and at the
end of the day I think crowdfunding
should literally be just like begging on
the streets your last option
have you tried absolutely everything to
get this movie made have you been trying
to make this movie for four years and
you've talked to everybody and you've
networked with everybody and nobody will
make it and your only option is
crowdfunding then go with that but if
you're Zach Braff and you're like hey
yeah I want to you know fund a movie
it's ridiculous
if crowdfunding is your only way of
getting the movie made I think that's
great and I've seen some people do it
and it's their first movie and power to
them I think that's great and I'm not
going to knock on them that's who it's
made for it's made for people to start
but if you've already made a movie and
you're already making movies and you can
go out and get a movie made then it's
you're robbing from the people who can
and it's messed up to do and I I'm I'm
very against crowdfunding I mean seeing
seeing people like you know Spike Lee
going out and crowdfunding you've got to
be kidding me
that's ridiculous let's suppose there's
other indie film makers and you have
over a hundred thousand Twitter
followers and let's say we hit another
recession or for some reason the
investors that you have aren't able why
would it be bad if people like your work
and you went to them
for $100 each $25 each you have your
movie right there do you feel that it's
it makes it look like you can't get
investors well one I do feel like it
makes it look like you can't get
investors and also if you don't reach a
crowdfunding goal you have a permanent
stamp on the internet saying I couldn't
raise this much money for my fans but
another thing that I think makes me
really against crowdfunding is I think
it's kind of like an illegal basis
almost because you're basically having
people invest in a project without
getting anything on the back end which I
think I think it's wrong and I am not
really I'm not a fan of it
I also think that because crowdfunding
is so spread out and so many people do
it there's there's also like stuff like
IndieGoGo where you don't have to meet
the goal and you get to keep the money
well if you don't meet the goal did you
just keep everybody's money and not make
the movie because I've seen plenty of
movies that just didn't get made and
they took people's money it's I think
it's I think I think it's there's gonna
be it's almost like racketeering and
like there's there's some problems with
it and I think it needs to be more
streamlined I think a better thing would
be crowdfunding in a sense that I go I
don't have a budget but I want to get
this movie made who will donate their
time for me not their money their time
will you DP and bring your camera for
free will you run sound for me for free
will you handle all the craft services
and feed everybody like will you act for
free I think that's a much better way
you post your idea of your film and see
who's willing to donate their time to be
involved because time is money but
that's you're not taking people's
hard-earned cash right I think that
sounds great I think you're right in the
cases where people don't complete
something even if they make their goal I
think that's wrong but for the people
that do send updates they send you the
screener they send you whatever it is
you don't feel that that's the right no
I said completely power to those people
oh I think a lot of those people who do
that it's because it's their first movie
or it's you know they're going out but
I'm saying people like Spike Lee people
like you know Zach Braff they shouldn't
be doing that stuff Veronica Mars
shouldn't have been a kick-started
project and I feel like it'd be wrong if
I did it and I I'm I'm against it for
that because I don't want to take
advantage of my fans and people that
watch my stuff I I respect the fact that
they watch it and also a lot of people
are broke nowadays I don't want
take you know you're saying oh it's only
20 bucks but 20 bucks is a lot of money
if somebody doesn't have 20 bucks so
it's not even a tank of gas yeah I mean
I have a ton of fans of my movies they
watch them on Netflix because they can't
afford to buy the DVDs have you been
tempted to pull the trigger and say let
me just make a video and throw out the
campaign and just see what happened I've
been tempted multiple times to to do a
Kickstarter but then I go you know it
needs to be my last my last option and
you know I'm doing okay without the
Kickstarter projects and you know I I
think obviously I'm very vocally against
it and Kickstarter will hate me for it
but I I just I think it's I on a base
level inside myself I feel that it's
wrong and I just inside me I feel that
it's the wrong thing to do and I feel
like it's I feel like it's begging sure
it's not an uncommon you know idea how
close have you been to actually getting
a campaign ready and then what caused
you to recoil no I I never I just had a
thought a couple of times I was like
this is a weird idea but I can't get
anybody to fund it because it'd be too
like crazy maybe I'll put it on
Kickstarter but I never did
I really those thoughts only really came
when Kickstarter was like first coming
out and everybody was like oh and you
saw all these campaigns popping up like
every week and so at the end of the day
I think that there's too many kinks to
work out with the system before I can be
totally sold on it
you